[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
wir hoffen sie haben die hitze wurde
überstanden in allen einen schönen guten
abend ich bin wieder am tag der mit
christian otto hier später mit den
sportlichen news flott gebündelt guten
abend und wir blicken auf die themen an
diesem mittwoch
streit um die gasturbine kanzler scholz
sagt sie könne jederzeit nach russland
gebracht werden moskau bemängelt
fehlende unterlagen
drohgebärden nach pelosi besucht china
demonstriert seine militärmacht als
reaktion auf den besuch der us
spitzenpolitikerin in taiwan
und es wird noch heißer in deutschland
der höhepunkt der aktuellen hitzewelle
steht bevor in den ersten regionen wird
das wasser knapp
seit juni drosselt russland die gasmenge
nach deutschland und begründet dies mit
einer defekten turbine alles
vorgeschoben sagt die bundesregierung
schon länger und der bundeskanzler hat
das heute auch noch mal sehr plakativ
unterstrichen bei einem termin in
mülheim an der ruhr sah er sich die
fertig gewartete turbine an und machte
deutlich an der technik kann es nicht
liegen karl hinterleitner
sie ist fast 20 tonnen schwer und soll
die lösung für deutschlands
gasversorgung bringen wochenlang war der
verbleib dieser turbine aus
sicherheitsgründen geheim heute haben
sie kanzler scholz in mülheim an der
ruhr persönlich in augenschein
seine botschaft die turbine ist
startklar was mir wichtig es ist klar zu
machen dass diese turbine jederzeit
einsetzbar ist und dass sie genutzt
werden kann es steht nichts ihren
weitertransport nach russland entgegen
gazprom er wirkte stets den eindruck als
hinge fast die ganze versorgung an
dieser turbine ohne sie könne man eben
nur 20 prozent gas liefern doch jetzt wo
das gerät da ist fehlen angeblich
unterlagen für die einfuhr so heißt es
auch heute wieder aus moskau
gründe die offenbar nur vorgeschoben
sind aus unserer sicht sind alle papiere
zollpapiere transport papiere so weit
wie es vorbereiten können vorbereitet
alle vorgebrachten technischen sind
nicht auf einer faktenbasis
nachvollziehbar und das glaube ich
gehört auch zur wahrheit dazu auch
ex-kanzler und putin freund gerhard
schröder meldet sich zu wort im stern
-interview befürwortet ihr die
inbetriebnahme von nord stream 2 sie ist
fertig wenn es wirklich eng wird gibt es
diese pipeline und mit beiden nord
stream pipeline als gäbe es kein
versorgungsproblem für die deutsche
industrie und die deutschen haushalte
ein versorgungsproblem gäbe ist
allerdings auch nicht wenn dort stream 1
wieder vertragsgemäß mit voller kraft
liefert doch dass das passiert und
russland den gashahn wieder ganz öffnet
scheint zurzeit mehr als zweifelhaft
wir wollen die situation einordnen mit
filme gar in moskau und mathis feldhoff
in berlin mattes was sollte dieser
termin von olaf scholz heute bewirken na
das war eine ziemlich klare botschaft
die ihr olaf scholz heute gesendet hat
russland liegt die turbine ist da und
sie wäre einsatzbereit scholz botschaft
das ist alleine russland das die
lieferung verzögert und das damit
deutlich macht dass es bereit ist gas
auch als druckmittel und waffe
einzusetzen
wer das gegenteil behauptet wie etwa der
russische regierung sprecher peschke
oder altkanzler gerhard schröder sage
halt nicht die wahrheit er ist sicher
nicht nur einstieg nahe von scholz an
wladimir putin sondern auch an die
eigene bevölkerung nicht auf die
russische propaganda hereinzufallen
scholz will dieser russischen propaganda
etwas entgegensetzen die ja behauptet
dass die sanktionen schuld sind an
dieser gaskrise es habe keinen besseren
tag für die scholz fotos mit dieser
turbine geben können sagte heute ein
regierungsvertreter mit blick auf das
interview von putin freund gerd schröder
weiter nach moskau zu filme also hier
wird gesagt alles sei bereit und lege
vor moskau müsse sich nur melden wo
liegt also das problem
ja aus moskauer sicht wenig überraschend
liegt das problem in deutschland genauer
gesagt bei siemens energy gazprom bleibt
bei seiner haltung dass die dokumente
fehlen würden die für den
weitertransport der turbine notwendig
sind insgesamt ist es so dass diese
turbine eben wirklich der perfekte beleg
für russland ist um sein negativ zu
spinnen das narrativ dass die westlichen
sanktionen dem westen mehr schaden
würden als sich selber ich nenne mal
drei punkte erstens die turbine fällt
zwar nicht unter eu sanktionen aber eben
unter kanadische sanktionen für russland
bedeutet dass der westen ist sich nicht
einig zweitens deutschland bittet kanada
darum eine ausnahme von den sanktionen
zu machen und für russland belegt dass
wie abhängig deutschland von russischem
gas ist und drittens kanada gewährt
diese ausnahme und in russland wächst
dadurch die hoffnung dass es vielleicht
auch in anderen bereichen möglich sein
könnte die sanktionen aufzuweichen wenn
man nur genug druck aufbaut danke für
die einschätzung nach moskau für begann
nach berlin mathis feldhoff
ja man muss kein prophet sein um
vorherzusagen kommenden herbst und
winter wird es für ziemlich viele
ziemlich hart durch den krieg
galoppierenden preise vor allem bei der
energie werden zu extremen belastungen
führen und auch wenn der kanzler heute
noch einmal betonte man werde helfen die
vorboten sind längst da und lassen
verbraucher verzweifeln nieder die bei
berichtet
die post vom gasanbieter treibt ihnen
fast tränen in die augen bald müssen
eileen und stefanie ermeling aus quellen
mehr als das doppelte zahlen sie haben
angst dass das geld dann nicht mehr
reicht jetzt steigen die
lebensmittelpreise die spritpreise
was wir vor allem mit seit einem monat
extrem merken
und jetzt mit dem gas
ist natürlich
also wir haben uns gestern angeguckt und
gefragt was machen sollen
der kölner energieversorger rheinenergie
hebt ab oktober die gaspreise deutlich
an während einer mittelgroßen wohnung
lebt zahlt dann jährlich 2002 euro
vorher waren es rund 960 ein anstieg um
108 prozent
andere gasanbieter haben längst erhöht
teilweise noch drastischer im
durchschnitt 184 prozent im laufe eines
jahres wie ein vergleichsportal
ermittelt die gas umlage ab herbst noch
nicht eingerechnet es gab ja einige
entlastungen die aber eben alle zu ende
august auch ändern werden gleichzeitig
kommt im herbst die umlage und die
preiserhöhungen die damit verbunden ist
hier klafft tatsächlich eine
gerechtigkeitslücke untergrund muss mit
einem neuen hilfspaket zielgerichtet
denjenigen helfen die jetzt bereits mit
dem rücken zur wand stehen kanzler
scholz verweist auf die pläne seiner
regierung
und wir werden weitere maßnahmen
ergreifen gerade da wo es knapp es im
geldbeutel weil viele bürgerinnen und
bürger hier keine rücklagen haben
aufbauen können deshalb unsere
entscheidung dass wir das wohngeld
substanziell ausbauen und verbessern und
dass wir auch die reform der
grundsicherung zum ersten januar 23 auf
den weg bringen aylin und stefanie
ermeling sind skeptisch dass es damit
für mehr reicht als bloßes überleben sie
bekommen ein kind wollten eigentlich in
eine drei zimmer wohnung umziehen das
können sie sich im moment aber einfach
nicht leisten
nach dem besuch der us
spitzenpolitikerin nancy pelosi in
taiwan lässt china militärisch die
muskeln spielen vor rund drei stunden
meldet taipeh also die hauptstadt
taiwans das eindringen von 27
chinesischen kampfflugzeugen in die
heimische luft verteidigungszone china
droht mit weiteren gezielten
militäraktionen und beansprucht taiwan
für sich über die möglicherweise nächste
große krise ulf röller
dieses treffen wollte china unbedingt
verhindern die vorsitzende des us
repräsentantenhauses nancy pelosi
begrüßt von der taiwanesischen
präsidentin sein wenn die botschaft an
peking die usa werden taiwans
eigenständigkeit verteidigen
per los sie weiß um die schlagkraft
ihrer worte weiß dass sie die region
erschüttern werden
wir fühlen uns taiwans sicherheit
verpflichtet und wir wollen dass sich
das land selbst verteidigen kann es geht
um demokratie und um freiheit die taiwan
so vorbildlich repräsentieren
während glos sieht diese worte spricht
hat china schon seit stunden seine
truppen in marsch gesetzt
die machthaber haben befohlen sich
militärübungen um taiwan abzuhalten für
peking ist taiwan eine abtrünnige insel
die zum festland china gehört mit
scharfer munition übt die truppe peking
will eine vereinigung mit taiwan
notfalls mit militärischer gewalt
erreichen taiwan ist nie ein
eigenständiges land gewesen historisch
gesprochen ist es eine provinz der
volksrepublik china
pelosis besuch hat die region
durchgerüttelt china will ab morgen mit
einem großmanöver taiwan umzingeln
präsident wie wild stärke zeigen auch um
daheim nicht schwach zu wirken
nancy pelosi ist abgereist aber ihr
besuch wird nachwirken an chinas strand
rund 160 kilometer entfernt von taiwans
küste rollen demonstrativ die panzer
peking inszeniert bisher nur eine
schlacht der bilder
jetzt zum krieg in der ukraine und den
auswirkungen der in odessa gestartete
und mit mais beladene frachter hat die
nächste hürde genommen wurde inspiziert
und hat die fahrt richtung libanon
fortgesetzt drei stunden lang hatten
kontrolleure aus russland der türkei der
ukraine und den vereinten nationen den
frachter im hafen von istanbul
durchsucht und die frachtpapiere
kontrolliert zu beanstanden hatten sie
nichts die ratio nie ist das erste
schiff des seit kriegsbeginn die ukraine
verlassen konnte
die internationale atomenergiebehörde
blickt mit sorge auf den atommeiler
sapporo cia im besetzten teil der
ukraine alle grundsätze nuklearer
sicherheit würden dort verletzt sagte
der chef der iaa sabrina ist das größte
kernkraft europas russische truppen
hatten es anfang märz besetzt der
fordert jetzt den experten zugang zu
ermöglichen
brutal und blutig tobt der ukraine krieg
weiter dort verteidigen nicht nur
berufssoldaten die front es sind männer
die vorher als ingenieure als busfahrer
oder tischler gearbeitet haben aber auch
viele frauen die früher im berufsleben
standen greifen in dieser dramatischen
situation zu den waffen anne brühl
konnte zwei von ihnen nahe der südlichen
frontlinie begleiten ihr kampfname ist
hexe den haben wir die männer im team
gegeben aus respekt hexe ist der liter
soldat in der ukrainischen armee wir
dürfen sie beim training begleiten
unweit der front
meine tägliche aufgabe ist es zu
trainieren weil jede kampf mission
vorbereitung braucht das gilt für dich
persönlich und für deine waffe dafür
fühle ich mich verantwortlich
scharfschützen wie hexe operieren ganz
nah an den feindlichen linien
ob sie manchmal angst habe fragen wir
sie ja ich bin doch ein mensch ihr
gesicht möchte sie nicht zeigen ob und
wie viele russen sie in diesem krieg
getötet hat weil sie uns nicht sagen nur
so viel sie trifft aus einer entfernung
von 900 metern
hexe ist eine von vielen frauen die für
die streitkräfte der ukraine kämpfen
38.000 soldatinnen gibt es ist eine der
höchsten frauenquoten weltweit
auch valentina sven tosca hat sich
freiwillig gemeldet früher war sie
anwältin jetzt kann auch sie sich
vorstellen zur waffe zu greifen
wenn ich keinen unterschied zwischen mir
und den männern ich bin bereit mein land
zu verteidigen
an der südlichen front vermeldet die
ukraine gerade die rückeroberung
einzelner dörfer es ist der abschnitt an
dem auch hexe ist sie will weiterkämpfen
wie so viele frauen in der ukraine
und einen längeren bericht über die
ukrainischen kämpferinnen zeigt das
auslandsjournal um 22 uhr 15
mehr als 30 jahre ist der brandanschlag
auf eine asylbewerberunterkunft in
saarlouis her jetzt hat die
bundesanwaltschaft anklage wegen mordes
erhoben gegen einen 50-jährigen mann
bestehe hinreichender tatverdacht das
feuer aus rechtsextremistischen motiven
gelegt zu haben ein mann aus ghana kamen
damals ums leben zwei weitere erlitten
schwere verletzungen
heute sagt die polizei die ermittlungen
damals waren unzureichend sie wurden
schnell eingestellt erst vor zwei jahren
wurden sie dann nach neuen hinweisen
wieder aufgenommen
die ampel regierung in berlin hat sich
auf neue corona regeln für herbst und
winter verständigt lockdown sind tabu
dafür soll vom erster oktober an einem
masten pflicht im fernverkehr und den
kliniken gelten außerdem test pflichten
für krankenhäuser und pflegeheime
schärfere regeln können dann die
bundesländer erlassen die details hat
heike slansky
noch ist hochsommer doch der dritte
corona herbst steht vor der tür seit
wochen ringen zwei ampel minister
lauterbach und buschmann gesundheit und
justiz spd und fdp um ein
massnahmenpaket heute der durchbruch das
instrument maske stadt lockt alle diese
dinge die man unter dem begriff lockdown
versteht ausgangssperren
betriebsschließung schulschließung all
diese dinge halten wir nicht mehr für
angemessen
ab oktober bis ostern soll bundesweit
einen zweistufenplan gelten ffp zwei
maske entfernen und flugverkehr in
krankenhäusern und pflegeeinrichtungen
und betrieben zusätzlich können die
bundesländer weitere maßnahmen festlegen
ft2 maske im nahverkehr in öffentlichen
innenräumen maske oder tests in
restaurants und freizeiteinrichtungen
ausnahme frisch genießen oder geimpfte
neu ist eine verkürzte zeitspanne für
geimpfte nach also der definition die
wir ja einsetzen drei monate das heißt
also hier muss die dritte mindestens die
dritte oder an der weitere impfung
höchstens drei monate zurückliegen an
schulen sollen ab der fünften klasse
eine medizinische maske und tests
möglich sein kritik kommt unter anderem
aus bayern es fehlten konkrete vorgaben
wann was gilt gut gemeint ist noch lange
nicht gut gemacht da sind noch viele
viele fragen die es zu klären gilt im
vollzug ich hätte mir gewünscht dass es
einfacher ist auch für den bürger die
länder sollen künftig selbst entscheiden
je nach lage das konzept mehr
eigenverantwortung und spielraum für
verschärfungen
es ist sommer und deutschland ächzt
unter der nächsten hitzewelle aber sie
wissen es ist nicht nur heiß es ist
gleichzeitig auch viel zu trocken hier
zum beispiel die aktuellen
bodenverhältnisse bis in einer tiefe von
1,8 metern gelb heißt bereits
ungewöhnlich trocken und je dunkler das
rot desto außergewöhnlicher ist die
derzeitige dürre phase das hat folgen
auch für unseren umgang mit wasser
franziska von tiesenhausen mit
beispielen die stellvertretend für viele
gegenden in deutschland stehen
potsdam im sommer immer wieder sind die
pegelstände zu niedrig aus seen und
flüssen darf deshalb kein wasser mehr
entnommen werden wer dagegen verstößt
riskiert ein bußgeld von bis zu 50.000
euro für leitungswasser gibt es noch
keine beschränkung zur erleichterung
vieler kleingärtner denn geregnet hat es
kaum
ich versuche
abends oder vorher zu kommen und zu
springen ansonsten antiken es ist schon
schwierig und man muss viel gießen in
schmitten im taunus ist die lage noch
schwieriger die gemeinde hat den
trinkwasser notstand ausgerufen das
heißt für das blumengießen autowaschen
und vieles mehr darf kein wasser aus der
leitung mehr benutzt werden nachts wird
das wasser zeitweise ganz abgestellt
verständnis hat man das schon für und
steckt die leute sehen dass auch ein
dass man damals sparen muss nein
weiß den leuten unfair finde die gattin
bewässern müssen weil jetzt verdirbt
alles es ist extrem trocken in
deutschland und nach einem
wetterumschwung sieht es erstmal nicht
aus was wir hier spüren ist ganz klar
die klimakrise über jahre hinweg war es
jetzt viel zu trocken wir hatten extreme
dürre jahre und 2022 scheint auch so ein
jahr zu werden auch in herzberg am harz
spüren die menschen die auswirkungen des
heißen und trockenen sommers im user
haben sich giftige blaualgen rasant
vermehrt die bade saison ist jetzt schon
zu ende
wir sind jetzt beim sport christine die
vorfreude auf den start der fußball
bundesliga steigt freitag geht's los
pokalsieger rb leipzig zählt auch in der
neuen saison zu den favoriten natürlich
neben rekordmeister bayern münchen sowie
borussia dortmund und bayer leverkusen
die leipziger planen den titelkampf
möglichst lange sehr sehr spannend zu
halten auf augenhöhe mit den bayern
wollen sie seien dafür braucht leipzig
vor allem tempo und will dafür timo
werner zurück 33 millionen euro fordert
chelsea und leipzig kommt noch auch mit
neuzugang nationalspieler david raum hat
leipzig einen für angriffslust
verkörpert ich will dieser mannschaft
hier helfen ich will sie verstärken und
dann werden wir mal sehen wie sehr wir
bayer ärgern können dafür setzt leipzig
auch auf kontinuität konrad laimer ist
noch da topscorer christopher nun cocoa
seinen vertrag verlängert und auch der
noch verletzte kiosk radio bleibt 80
millionen euro von manchester city hat
leipzig abgelehnt
mit josip guardiola jemand her
für uns extrem wichtig ist extrem
wichtig ist nach der 3 5 niederlage
gegen die bayern im supercup ist klar
leipzig braucht ihn nach pokalsieg und
champions league quali will rwe die
euphorie auch in dieser saison entfachen
am 11 august beginnen in münchen die
european championships live zu sehen in
de und hier bei uns im zdf das design
der medaillen die neuen sportarten
vergeben werden erinnert an die
olympischen sommerspiele 72 an selber
stelle mit unterschiedlichen
schattierungen der einzigartigen zelt
dachkonstruktion im olympiapark
wie einst usain bolt so heute letzte
tebogo aus botswana der 19-jährigen
gewinnt bei den u20-weltmeisterschaften
in cali kolumbien die 100 meter in 9,91
sekunden junioren weltrekord schneller
als bolt im gleichen alter die sieger
gesten fast genauso wie die des früheren
sprintstars der den erfolg des newcomers
sofort auf seinen social media kanälen
verbreitet
tja so schnell kann krass ne danke
christin wir sind jetzt bei den
gewinnzahlen vom lotto und die gänse 5
11 13 21 40 43 und die superzahl 9
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und auf der zdf textseite 557 ja
sie können schon mal überlegen was sie
morgen anziehen werden es wird richtig
richtig heiß mehr gleiche wetter mit
intel wir empfehlen das heute journal um
21.45 mit christian sievers sagen danke
fürs interesse und schönen abend bis
morgen
[Musik]
schongau und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter wieder haben wir eine wetterlage
wo die hitze aus dem südwesten zu uns
kommen von spanien über frankreich nach
deutschland das gab es in diesem sommer
schon mehrfach ja und der höhepunkt der
hitze ist dann morgen sie erreicht uns
dann aus dem südwesten wird aber dann
von der kaltfront abgedrängt die uns
dann morgen abend erreicht hier an der
kommenden nacht kaum was los die sterne
funkeln vom himmel und das bei
temperaturen teilweise um 20 grad und in
den großstädten geht es auch kaum
darunter also eine enorme hitze
belastung und morgen dann viel
sonnenschein zum nachmittag kommen dann
von nordwesten schauer und gewitter auf
und die können schon heftiger ausfallen
bei höchsten temperaturen bis 39 grad im
südwesten deutschlands die 40 ist auch
noch drin 37 grad im osten ja und morgen
abend dann setzten sich die schauer und
gewitter weiterhin landet ins
landesinnere ford metalls starkregen
sturmböen und hagel
ja und die nächsten tage am freitag
weiterhin heftige gewitter die sich
richtung südosten durchsetzen bis 35
grad oder ab samstag nicht mehr ganz so
heiß ein schöner abend